speaking of uncomfortable there's
something that we didn't get to
yesterday that we should have all right
and it was it was there's a story in
Nashville about the mayor oh my god
possibly having an affair with her
bodyguard was a cop right with her
bodyguard and I was like how is anybody
gonna get to the bottom of this yeah and
thank God
Phil Williams was there yeah Phil
Williams really cuts through all the
imma walk in the Myer Myers right he
gets right to it right yeah and then and
and he is a guy that you can trust to
break through with the actual news not
the fake news yeah not the phone enos
but and he delivers it in a way that is
it's palatable it's it's it's something
that you can accept and understand yeah
you know you don't sit there and wonder
how on earth could this guy be a news
anchor how on this how on earth would
this guy be an on-air reporter that
never comes up yeah you know well this
was a good story what are they doing
yeah I don't know the audio down look up
the video where's Phil Williams because
our system is not working let's go Phil
Williams Nashville that's mayor I'm
sorry I thought the we're just gonna
play the audio Rob's too confused it
somehow the audio is taking longer than
the video said can I talk about musicals
more type-in Phil you want more bubbles
eh yeah more Bobo stories please ph IL
williams
nashville we're just mayor yeah
nashville mayor mayor yeah we're go to
videos don't be sorry just do it right
how do you like that Rob there you go
look at that hey Rob well that's what I
had this before and then he came in and
started troy barons across there delet
screwed up again
it was yeah it's it's it's not a delight
of shoots of FTP issue you know I faded
things in yeah
but by the way did you notice that droid
took the opportunity to throw the bus
yeah I don't blame them I mean I kind of
liked it he was like by the way I can't
believe it yeah because otherwise Troy
knows that would get blamed on operator
error but in this scenario it was not
his fault no it was assistant you should
go back to the beginning because where
they start talking and tell you what it
is this is the beginning okay sorry
what do you say to them we know that
boys don't mate
Nashville's mayor insists she will not
resign even as she admits to a two-year
affair with a police officer paid by
taxpayers major isn't that amazing
exactly this is just the introduction oh
okay okay
isn't that I mean the story is kind of
you don't hear about female politicians
doing this cheating on their husbands
with other dudes right that often I
don't know I'm kind of turned on this
mayor in Nashville seems like good egg
have quite a good egg I really Troy
could she
she wasn't mayor yeah if you just find
out all right I mean part of it like I
don't know I think it's just that you
find out she's a woman that cheated on
her husband with this cop guy that was
around her and it's like oh she wants it
oh by the way I know a woman who might
want to [ __ ] Troy oh geez Wow really you
found one gee Erin why no we're talking
about cuckolding yeah and I've chatted
with a cuckold couple you want it so a
so a woman wants you to watch another
[ __ ] Troy no there are a couple weird
there are a couple that very nice yeah
and I was actually asking them legit
questions things I'm just curious about
and the wife thinks Troy is really hot
so I said I would pass the message along
do cuckolding for the show would you do
that while her husband watches yeah man
I don't even know if he has to watch
have you done that before no don't be a
jerk she's very attractive
Troy let's do it okay well you know the
husband doesn't have to watch I mean I
mean I have a girlfriend now so I know
but it's for the show I mean I'd like to
at least see what you look like for sure
[Laughter]
from my own knowledge I mean you didn't
have to know right cuz that's not that's
not I playing with fire or anything like
that me just see a photo I'm gonna talk
to e go boost as you're listening just
slide in Detroit's DMS it's done yeah
hold on she's gonna she's really sexy no
boy jeez is your girlfriend into any
open stuff I don't know how long you
been together uh serious for only a
couple months yeah now is the time now
at the time break her into the fact that
you're a piece of [ __ ] immediately yeah
no she knows I liked it but I mean I
mean maybe it's like it's not really
cheating if you're the subject of a
cuckolding fantasy right you think
you're doing it because you're uh you're
a piece of meat in this scenario yeah I
think I think I think she'd be fine
they're fans of the radio show right and
they're fans at the end of the day yeah
that's always we it's just we don't want
to lose our listener base well Troy has
a girlfriend so maybe he doesn't want to
do it alright I think what if your
girlfriend [ __ ] the husband yeah oh no
I'm not into that he's open - all that
no I mean you know two girls are great
but yet not forget another okay
I just watched before I forgot it and
speed this reminded me of it no I mean
I'd still like to see the picture you
know what's funny Troy has told Jim he's
like I have a girlfriend now and it is
difficult to like be in a relationship
because of you know my desires and sure
and then Jim like just in the middle of
the show goes by the way Troy I know a
girl who wants to [ __ ] you like no well
because we're talking about cuckolding
that would be like that I mean it's
literally it would be like if an
alcoholic came in and you're like oh
good news we got free booze like if I
have a brewery you at least want to
smell smell the what I do that's
terrible it's Tara no alcoholic should
not go to the brewery and smell you have
to taste it do you think that there
might be a little bit of temptation yeah
you're right you're right if anything
Troy you've demonstrated it's your
amazing willpower I've been trying to be
good yeah right that won't even show
you'd like to see the photo he's an
adult he can make his own go over and
check out the photo check it out let's
take a look at the floor it's on
one photo what's the worst that could
happen oh geez okay she's a big penis
around yeah Oh God
but still I mean yeah here's another
picture Troy okay there's another photo
this is not Jim is a terrible info [ __ ]
okay and you know what's even worse
about this as somebody who can
sympathize with what Troy's going
through in gym in the fact that he has
also difficulty in in monogamous
relationships of his exploits instead of
being there and being like Troy I know
what you're going through let's make
this easier he's like all good news Troy
here's what you could be having today on
a pottery Shh I'm doing that yeah he's a
sexy man I literally was they asked
about Troy and I'm like hey look why not
maybe she ate that Jim that's cool I'm
trying to pass on the message you don't
think it's like if having a heroin
addict and being like look I just know
that there's a guy with free heroin
right over there yeah but you don't have
to go I'm just saying I wasn't thinking
of it for that reason I was only
thinking cuz they asked about Troy and
Troy was in here yesterday who's Phil
Williams he's talking with the mayor
[ __ ] some guy sewing oh my god I
forgot about this bestest for Troy that
cuckolding that whole thing's weird
especially if like the guys watching
them I don't know if he has to watch
though I think they're the kind of
couple it's not a random question I'm
just fascinated with the lifestyle like
because they're really into it and I'm
almost like do it like I was just asking
like legit questions yeah and they I
think that she does it without him
they're not even know where they live
I've no idea what part of the country
the revenant actually on this same line
of questioning and conversation line one
has a pretty important question okay yes
yeah what's up D in Georgia
yes yeah I was wondering if
Kelsey will make him bubble where bag
are you gonna make bubble where condom
wearing those on whom they can wear 25
condo okay alright well that at least
give a little extra girth love the
senior boyfriend you lose respect for
your boyfriend thank you if all he
wanted to do is watch you and Bobo
together while he sat in the corner yes
you think that's how the conversation
starts she'd get home and they did
whatever there'd be a little pillow
talking and he got yeah it would be
funny it's like you did enough having
sex is like right in front of me like
how crazy would that be what yeah so
weird right and Kelsie be like yeah
really weird and you'd be like yeah but
I mean not that we're right and then it
just got strange or anything but if I
weren't a dress well then happen oh
we're just like yeah yeah we should even
like we should even do it for the story
we should do it for the story imaginable
spank me first yeah yeah like imagine if
Bobo told me to shut up because it was
Bobo time that body I just again I feel
like with everything human mr.potato the
first person that's surprised yeah no
one's out yeah well again because you
guys have so many people around that I
feel like would do it for just for the
story or to show for yeah yeah everybody
usually when we say that the reaction is
oh good there's justice in the universe
people feel like he shouldn't be right
getting laid yeah okay let's just do I
want to hear Phil Ian's talk yeah yes so
this mayor in Nashville [ __ ] her body
go [ __ ] her bodyguard and they found
out yeah and then she was like well
guess what I'm not stepping down because
if I stepped down it's gonna be harder
to [ __ ] yeah I think right taking a
trooper dick he thinks he is
yeah of course she is oh yeah three hole
three hole in the mayor nice just a
wholesome bath and Bodyworks face like
she's in the mall and I like even look
like the teachers that are like just
nice-looking sweet looking girls that
have affairs with their students yeah
really [ __ ] hot oh my because it's so
dirty it's like well she was a good wife
so she blew the thirteen-year-old oh my
god
yeah do you like [ __ ] 18 year old
that's one thing
you as a man continue if your wife [ __ ]
a 13 year old his mustache was starting
to come in and he was really beginning
to look like a man yeah and he had such
eagerness to him yeah go out and play
soccer right sometimes his fingers were
sticky from his fruit snacks at lunch
but he would just wash them off yeah
yes sometimes I'd suck his dick so good
he dropped his juice box yeah his breath
always smells like popsicles it was so
sexy yes we learned from Quentin the
other day it's not that big a deal right
because the 13 year old was into it yeah
you see there's an interview from
Quentin Tarantino from like 2000 2003 or
something like that know where he did
say that technically in his opinion
hopeless Roman Polanski did not rape the
thirteen-year-old girl because she was
very into it and then she liked doing
the pills in the alcohol and sex with
the man yes yeah so I probably am on the
other side of that fence like I would
actually disagree with Tarantino I
disagree but he makes great movies I
disagree but there's still not a
Tarantino movie I won't watch right I
love them
right even you know what's it what's
underrated is a death Proof I love that
death Proof what are you laughing at
just a request I got what are you doing
over there
you got a share oh sure
it's either cuckolding or bit coining
like you know know either of those
things
Oh Oh No is it teasing somebody huh no
I'll let everybody see it you will okay
yeah okay hold on okay you guys keep
talking okay well I don't want to play
the Phil Williams thing until you're
ready oh you'd be too second yeah yeah
no no would take your time I don't mind
as long as we get to see it like in the
moment and we won't spoil it but you get
to hear all of our reaction to it and
don't show Travis I won't show Travis
Travis normal voice right here
well you shouldn't see like the Toby
from the office no sherry I shared it
with everyone
oh you text it on Twitter oh you tweeted
it okay
go to Jim Norton on Twitter Travis don't
look at Twitter I'm going to take
Twitter off your phone Travis fine
okay yesterday it's a $6 request and the
response is eat my ass the second one is
today all this talk of big coin I wanted
to get into my cyber currency or crypto
currency and I requested another $5 from
Jim and you want to click that image so
we can see because I haven't seen what
the response was there was no response
oh I know is that on top of the $6 are
you negotiating down I was like both
okay yeah I think 11 now so you just
wanted to share with everybody how you
responded yesterday this is what I'm
getting no I was anything in yesterday's
I'm also that you sent me two days of
Apple of requests for this is what I'm
dealing with
give my phone just vibrated while I'm
here my phone and so I just I looked at
it and I keep sending you a Apple pay
request yep yeah a terrible stored photo
you have Sam as your contact
I like there's me yeah long hair yeah
yeah you don't like to stunt the photo
the dragonballs me can see also got a
money request and we were within oh my
god within moments no convincing her
that if you hit pay she was like how do
I make this go away and we were like
wait if you pay you don't actually have
to pay she was like oh her finger was
hovering you guys are tricking me are
you if you hit pay then there's an
option that comes up and you can say not
oh okay great she was almost there yeah
that we almost had I don't have apple
player I were to say it's six bucks you
would have can you sign up forever I
tried yesterday would let me continue I
was showing you guys I'm with the [ __ ]
wrong with this piece of [ __ ]
you mean the operator or the phone one
piece of [ __ ] you work while the other
one is a [ __ ] dumb flunky failure
coming out of Philly going now let's
listen to Phil Williams as he uncovers
the seedy underbelly of a show of the
Asheville mayoral seat Megan berry
insists that she has not abused her
position and she says she hopes
Nashville will forgive her she sat down
with utilities good well the mayor made
the stunning admission this afternoon
just days after we began asking
questions about how she and her police
bodyguard bodyguard eyes are almost
touching his ears and his mouth opens in
the middle and then it's just it's glued
shut on the outside it was great but the
girl using your back a little bit so we
could see you know you were buddy
by the way Kelsie I want you to know
something after we featured him a few
months ago exposing somebody who was
must repeating yeah he won a mister baby
yeah
mr. baby must for baiting he won a local
Emmy yeah I did yeah well Phil Williams
is the [ __ ] yeah we love Phil oh he's
the greatest
would you interview him oh my god I
would he would be any of our co-hosts
with us he'd be here for the whole show
yeah he's probably too hard to get
anyway he's got to figure out what's
going on in Nashville he's got to get to
the bottom of everything in Nashville is
that where he lives
what's in yes I think this is local news
and nails grow yeah yeah heard that is
awful there's a lot in pants was
terrible on her
what do you mean the wide leg pants are
coming back in stock she looks atrocious
licensed wide leg from hip to foot she's
your rectangle piece of wood wide leg
pants suits are big right now what are
you guys wearing we shooting an air up
into each other so deeply yes your fat
legs are three inches away from being
Hammer pants I used to wear them Hammer
pants he probably liked the awesome when
I started comedy my first head shot was
in Hammer pants we were like Zubaz
really skids online somewhere that we
can see yeah they were very very low
hanging boys you're gonna head shots did
you see that rich lost one yes jacket Oh
God
that's not good no very funny Bert
Kreischer oh yeah never forget yeah yeah
they like these kids Maris kids you know
they were hanger and Hammer pants
they're skid marks
I don't think Hammer had a Signature
Series pants no but they were like them
I'm saying yeah these are like that no
no okay they hung lower oh let's get
back to Phil well you know esta gate of
reporter bill Willington fell William
well the mayor made the stunning
admission this afternoon just days after
we began asking question her police
bodyguards used your money asking every
time I watch there's a new word that
he's having trouble with asking
questions like it's like the first
syllable is okay but he's like oh [ __ ]
there's a second syllable I might have
to push it's like he had a debilitating
childhood injury yeah and overcame it
like that's how he talks like the
wieszczyk took like this because my
throat was sung shut when I was a baby
every wearable everywhere is a battle
yes every word is a bat it's like he's
deaf there's something I probably deaf
any lip reads and he doesn't know how
sports come out yeah yeah I'm very
embarrassed I'm deeply ashamed and she's
not ashamed sorry
yeah she's ashamed
there's sopping wet hole I have messed
up your chair yeah I'm deeply ashamed
that my husband couldn't get the job
done so I'm [ __ ] this masculine state
trooper Oh
we were first informed of this by the
many wet chairs in the mayor's office
yes the furniture Brella had gotten very
high and they use your money let's hear
him talk when I had a she's coming right
now I can't say it without coming and I
have heard a lot of people with those
words mayor Meghan be readmitted what
she had long kept secret and ongoing
affair with this man police 2.0 boy and
her name Marion Barry mayor Barry did
you see Marion Barry
mayor Berry Megan Megan though I just
couldn't understand what you're saying I
mean of all the people this guy state
trooper bodyguard yeah he's a handsome
guy for her yeah that makes sense
yeah I mean she's not I would like to
see what her husband looks like yeah me
too
he's probably a little nerdy back into a
politico type guy little dumpy little
dumb a little bit of a betta getting
that mayor push at home yeah yeah here's
the state trooper who's like [ __ ] you in
your policy right in both holes
yeah the husband likes to talk about
these issues yeah the trooper doesn't
trooper just likes to get down to
business
yeah the true the trooper go is [ __ ]
asked him out she's dating Jesse Ventura
ghost of Sam Roberts future yeah hard to
believe that she was [ __ ] the mayor
the the cop yeah I mean counsel you can
admit now that is an upgrade Oh 1,000
he's in better shape and he's more
masculine oh yeah yes that guy just
became a 10 I want to hear how the he's
shifted how they found out wing affair
with this man police searched while
forest were fools to read by Nashville
taxpayers to protect their city's
highest elected official okay look hit
pause if you are you say it like that
yeah just used the used word economy
economy word yeah like yeah who's the
smallest amount of words be able to get
your stuff out because all these
syllables are only gonna give you
problems the mirror he really is an
awful way yeah the most highly trusted
the fools we he sounds like a robot
who's been programmed but he like can't
quite get the pronunciation right like
thank you so tell it's a row yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're that it's like an old
radio announcer thing cuz like a lot all
radio guys talk like that they always
talk with over given a different sort a
handicap it's a yes yeah because they're
at least getting their words out like
he's having trouble with yeah he's
struggling it sounds like he wants to do
that old timey radio thing cuz I know
exactly what you're talking about but
also he can't speak because the fact
that his mouth is song his mouth has
closed on the sides watch him talk to
Matt the middle open it's it's like he's
got his jaws
wired shut except only on the sides and
then oh yeah ruby has Bell's palsy could
be Bell's palsy
yeah maybe all over the people of
Nashville don't have to and I also want
to ask for their forgiveness
Oh Barry says the affair began accepting
that night the police veteran was
assigned to her protective detail and
force has been a constant presence with
the mayor during most of her public
appearances even as she admits the
affair was ongoing okay okay I mean he
gave up at the end of that get going
like it's like it's like he can't
breathe until his segments over so he's
just like trying to get all his words
out and were you fighting oh cool I want
to hear the number of takes that are
scrapped like I want to hear the ones
that Phil no good it must take forever
to clean your room can you imagine if
Phil lives has a 10-inch dick with Sony
and girth yes I'm going to ruin you for
the next man I'm going to rack that
policy director [ __ ] I mean he's a tall
guy you have to imagine that the
universe that creates us human beings
usually will make up for shortchanging
reality yeah right screaming you're
ruining my [ __ ] and he's like I'm not
even all the way hard I'm gonna fill you
[Laughter]
my name is is my nickname that's what I
do take it like a prostitute you were
sergeant force boss
why did you not say at some point if I'm
going to have this relationship
he needs to be removed from my detail
that was I should have so that was a
failure the mayor that was a failure
wait teacher lessons Phil get off her
case how about the fact that she's
married and that's the problem why
wouldn't you ever move from the detail
cuz first of all I wanna [ __ ] the guys
with you right they're always there
yeah cuz it was easier to have sex with
him when he was there yeah there's a
reason for him to be there
no one says why is that bodyguard like
if I wasn't have an affair do with club
soda Kenny no I'm gonna say I mean I've
hadn't seen in a while but you know been
yeah easy access right yeah I mean that
was a failure as the mayor then she's
got it there and be like well you're a
failure as a [ __ ] news reporter every
single day look how you talk that's what
I would have said if I were the mayor
get the hell out of this office Phil
Williams you're gonna teach me a lesson
you're not my you're not my teacher I
just want to take the guys job guys
we're trying to work for Williams no
exactly and when they're not [ __ ]
he's protecting her exactly like by the
way how much physical harm is she
encountered nothing fine eggs so is the
bodyguard not effective very effective
so there are people are paying for an
effective bodyguard yeah you want your
idea kill do you want her to get a dick
inside of her right taxpayers are
getting what they're paying for
and she's also getting a [ __ ] buddy that
she's a better bear and she's a better
beer for me she's coming right you
wonder if the husband knew or if he
didn't know like did the husband no was
it a [ __ ] situation was it she's
cheating yeah let's see she said she was
having an affair and cheating well she
has to say that she can't say my husband
knew but we have a unique relationship
is the cop married to dad I don't know
maybe Phil Williams will get to the
fellow at the bottom he wouldn't talk to
me talk to the club but he said they so
did he sounds like a muppet when he
talks yes Jim Henson creator because he
sounds like sam the eagle to say you
know this is something that's happening
and I should I should
remedy this I mean what I should have
done is not remedy had been a part of my
security detail whether or not I should
have owned up and not had the affair
right during 2017 travel records show
forests traveled with the mayor to San
Francisco Salt Lake City Washington
several times as well as he was getting
she was getting [ __ ] dick all over
this man was [ __ ] this guy he [ __ ]
her across the United States yeah and
there's the problem I'm still lost on
his inability to say the state's names
some Frances or city names so Frances
school sounds like the IRS called Jim
just got a really weird to call local
cops do you think they look at the
script and they be like oh boy
Jill it's got a full 45 second breaks at
all no it's gonna get rough can we just
say across the country no I wouldn't
name all the places two weeks ago but it
[Laughter]
is true she was also using clear
fingerprints you don't need to say all
those words Phil not necessary sometimes
you catch four ounces of liquid jump it
we heard you all at taxpayer expense
he even put it inside of her backside in
grease under his dollars hey mr. mayor
do you speak Greek business trips
absolutely every single one of them but
hadn't been sergeant forests who would
have been traveling with me as detailer
there would have been other not clearly
because the mayor of Nashville really
has to make sure to her relations with
Greece and Paris are good yeah why the
[ __ ] is the mayor of Nashville do they
all get one bodyguard though like when
they travel like is that part of being a
mayor well I'm sure because you
kidnapped her murder don't
official business she just said going to
Athens was on official business because
Nashville and Athens have to make sure
their allies and Paris yes or no I don't
know what mayor's do I don't what a
mayor of Nashville have to do in Paris
are there companies to I I don't know
again maybe she didn't pay it maybe she
was flown there by a car I don't know
yeah I'll tell you this I don't know
mayor Scarsdale never goes to Paris
because how does the husband [ __ ] you
know say okay unless they were going
with unless he went with the couple she
see that I want to see the husband again
I want you to talk to him he is kind of
a hottie he does that why that choice of
the hair if it's that ball just just
take everything off yeah I can't let go
what you looking at me Jim just look at
this screen I'm just you're my co-host
I'm stalking you
Kelsey was the one talking oh I mean
sorry
[Laughter]
uncalled for okay thank you look at my
coast well I wasn't talking to you okay
I mean I don't even know what you were
getting at to tell you the truth it's
weird mixed signals in here I don't
disagree
I like dicks alright let's play I'm
using that but take the bite an office
thing no I like it
you should have a limit to how many
weekly put presses of that button there
is a limit I haven't reached it 1500 I'm
well within the rain certainly with me
the the detail security policy is set by
the police department and they they say
I have to travel with security in fact
force provided protection for former
mayors bill Purcell and Karl Dean he
averaged thirty four thousand dollars a
year in overtime three years of Dean's
term but after Barry took office forced
overtime pay 25,000 motorists below
sixty thousand dollars in fiscal year
2015-16 the next year that increased to
more than a $75,000 see clearly overtime
was for considered a [ __ ] time wow so
that's where the problem is because this
guy's [ __ ]
jackin them for overtime she's [ __ ]
him so he's charging throat Matt what a
they got off a swinging dick this guy's
my idol he's a bodyguard gigolo I'll
[ __ ] the mayor and you're paying me time
and a half right yeah you want your
holes filled cuz that [ __ ] lump can't
do it time and a half [ __ ] good thing
everybody knows this dick ain't free
yeah no that's the expression I have for
myself for your own dick right I'm going
to do it and it's more of like an
exclamation this dick ain't free yeah
Wade have one placed in between your
yeah I got it cheatin gun no like a
pinch of skull right nice to hold the
penis please cheatin gun
what man would hold tobacco I like to
expand every time to compare oral sex to
dip my knots a perfect comparison I mean
I you know hold a dick in your mouth
like you don't suck it no just hold it
there no of course not you're annoyed
that your walkies gotta smell as pubes
yeah I'd like to feel the ridges of your
molars against the chef I have you I've
never held a dick in my mouth no you
know co-host don't have the same dating
habits I've never
I don't either why why what's on now
$57,000 for fiscal year 2016-17 some
people will look at that and say that
taxpayers are paying for this
relationship what would you say to them
that's what this reflects is again the
policy that the police have about making
sure that when I'm working that I have
detail and and I don't think it's a
secret that I do work a lot getting paid
by taxpayer at any point when you were
having your personal time when when you
all were having your person doesn't he
say well getting paid by taxpayer go
back he's a singular like it's one guy
footing the bill but she has to say no
where's she gonna go yeah he was [ __ ]
me on the dime
yeah I guess that is why people are mad
yeah we did pay him for the for the [ __ ]
time yeah that's it yeah we do that yeah
scene 17
some people will look at that something
that taxpayers are paying for this
relationship
watch what would you say to them what I
think what this reflects is again the
policy that the police have about making
sure that when I'm working that I have
detail and and I don't think it's a
secret that I do work a lot and I do
have a pretty aggressive schedule and
was he getting paid by taxpayer money
your taxpayer dollars yeah me any lost
confidence in his ability to say the
word dollars
yeah that's is extra two syllables I do
have it be so she only gets while she's
working like you know Bill DeBlasio
right mayor in New York San Francisco
Chicago they put it 20 he's the mayor of
all those yeah it's a really weird thing
he flies a lot Wow but the mayors of
these different majors should probably
have 24 police put a bill de blasio 25
polluters yeah she probably has it when
she's working so going to Paris but what
it brings security detail and that's
probably how you have excuses to have
this guy overnight because you're
overseas so what's he gonna do he has to
get paid for travel time I hope Phil
Williams points out that she's supposed
to have security when she's working not
when she's putting in that work let's
see ya know how can taxpayers know that
all of that over time was completely
legitimate I think that the records will
show if you look at my schedule could I
see your bodyguards figures or fist
smell your buddy good so you know what
that implies of course they do yes here
you're into feasting yeah you like it to
stretch to the point of giving birth at
my schedule reflects that I was out
there working the police sergeant was
also there that David berry and her
husband Bruce joined at Nashville in
mourning the death of have to live
through this like I was there to heaven
he says helps her keep this moment in
person
active you know the political world yeah
there may be some people who say she
cannot govern yeah for us resign what do
you say to them no this is a bad day I'm
gonna have a lot more bad days coming up
I've already had my worst day and and I
know the difference between a mistake
and a tragedy this is a mistake
her son died had he died okay listen
first of all she is trying to be like
look I know I might have [ __ ] my
bodyguard and maybe the state was paying
him but my son's dead so never sad
conversation the poor husband he loses
his son and his wife oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
he died in July 29th
in July he just [ __ ] died over this
oh man maybe Nathan and his wife was his
mother was sex with her bodyguard if the
guy was there that that's the point Phil
Elena's millions the bodyguard was there
yeah at the waist of the [ __ ] father
it's a way Hobart our son and some guy
your [ __ ] is with us our visa
bodyguard he would have to be there
right
he was that I thought was just saying
yeah so in this administration over the
last two years we've done a lot of
really good things and that's gonna
continue to be my focus as for her
future with her husband I can say now
that dee says that's for them to figure
out figure is a tough one for them to go
back to Sue's I think youse are a tricky
tricky G into the yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean as far as letters go that is
a tough one
yes that's a tough train you isn't
really good things and that's gonna
continue to be my focus as for her
future with her husband Barry says
that's for them to figure out whoa Corey
says I have a lot to work through and
we're working through it I'm really
blessed that I have a husband who was
supportive
me yeah you've been we've been through a
lot together and this is something that
personally we're gonna work through what
a guy yeah forest did I love the outro
veteran who suddenly retired effective
yesterday
well it's also married and an attorney
for his Phil Williams dig into the
bottom of it The Bodyguard is married he
retired now sent a letter to the police
department demanding that the his police
issued mobile phone be preserved as
possible evidence meanwhile this is all
a very quickly developing story we're
going to have more of our interview
later in this newscast and mayor berry
also plans to hold a news conference
later this evening and we're in the
process of posting some of the financial
documents that really covered all of
that and more coming up tonight on
newsChannel 5 . so what else so many
words so the kid died she's [ __ ] this
guy why'd the cop have to retire
immediately in the well the cop is it
the [ __ ] yeah why is he rushing if
they lose his career because he might
have been billing the state maybe
improperly yeah but again he's the
mayor's bringing him yeah yeah she is
bringing him to climax I guarantee you
she has to step down
I don't know this not because they be
the taxpayer money it's not gonna be the
morals of the affair it's gonna be the
taxpayer money that she this guy build
157 G's in two years and meanwhile three
years before that it was thirty two
thousand thirty seven thirty something
responsible that's right if you're in
Nashville you're not gonna get away with
[ __ ] Phil Williams is there I mean
like I wouldn't if Phil Williams was a
local reporter here in New York I would
mind my P's and Q's he's gonna get to
the bottom of it I really want to know
what happens with this [ __ ] story
happening this week now like in real
time or just like a month ago no no no
this is III think January also like a
week ago I want to make a Phil will yems
sex talk doll where you like pull the
string he says all the things can
somebody make that from sure I'm sure
the listeners here you know yeah your
legs you Pig
whichever Phil Williams impression
contest yeah though and then when the
winner gets a bullet in the mouth
make it stop forever